je ne sais pas je connaissais mais vous
êtes mieux éclairer maintenant ah oui
j'en arrive un jour où je n'ai pas
changé d'avis si j'en ai apporté qu'un
homme et d d d d d paris match on vous a
vu jamais eu plein oui mais enfin on m'a
vue oui mais je ne pose jamais avec
bernard andrieu moi j'étais vite hissé
dans froide en tout cas ce que cela n'a
maintenant c'est de la solidarité
j'aime beaucoup c'est une super
chanteuse avec ton mari dans gala et une
montre et amélie oui mais ça avait été
non non non non c'était bonnet névé
absolument des images volées
oui absolument et match aussi celles qui
ont été dans machete l'on peut jamais
savoir
non non toute façon on peut l'appeler
bernard il le dit lui-même d'ailleurs
même voulu nier la visite j'ai jamais
posé c'était des photos volées dans gala
ou bien d'éponger poser quand on l'a
fait une erreur ensemble oui non et 8
mai midi dans comédie son dernier
bouquin qui est plutôt un bon bouquin
d'ailleurs qui n'a pas été c'est inné
parle de lui dans la vie parle de lui
dit je vais essayer de bien interpréter
aide moi je l'aurais dit ce cabot ce
robot cet imprécateur pantine ise par
les télés emmagasinée par la presse
pipole ce philosophe sur papier glacé
je le trouve plus pathétique qu'odieux
lui qui parle de lui mais bien sûr parce
que vous savez comment a été écrit ce
lycée quand même plusieurs personnages
qui se répondent les uns les autres et
qu'il ya un crime et il ya la
marionnette qui répond il était déjà vu
vous connaître la marianne c'est la
marionnette ses rapports avec l'image on
a tous des rapports plus ou moins bon
avec l'image cool week est souvent loin
de ce qu'on est
alors voilà ce livre c'était un peu en
beaucoup mieux
je veux bien
bienvenue cas mais voila voila ca cette
voie là ah ben alaoui bin il y avait des
photographes à un jour d'un mariage au
moins de les tabasser parce qu'il y en a
qui tabasse le jour du mariage ça fait
quand même désordre geboers alors ya
jean photo mais tout à fait pour moi
aussi votre mariage
je le donnerai des ta femme te regarde
bon alors non voilà quoi donc alors on
va terminer parce qu'on peut pas non
plus passer la soirée là dessus alors
derrière vous je montre un document
voilà les passons aux documents comme ça
cette entente
nous allons téléspectateurs c'est donc
qu'il ya un regard belle ce que les
belges en mai dernier sur la liste et
dernier burlesque qui s'appelle noël
godin alias le gloupier oui mais
attendez je j'aimerais juste interveniez
bien vous allez intervenir l'agencé
specs aux gens non mais moi j'ai tenu
qu'à madame parce que c'est mon ne
connais pas qui est donc jette des
tartes à la crème sur les jeux les ont
connus alors il ya eu sarkozy bill gates
et eu patrick bruel et ppda il ya eu
deux camps du plantier il ya eu ce grand
échalas et bernard henri lévy voilà je
dis savent ce qu'on pense pas que ce
soit une attentat pâtissier et ça nous
arrive de recevoir des tartes nous aussi
si oui fait l'interview quand on fait
l'interview on met les gens on l'aimé
pas longueur de bras
vous avez dit bernard henry a contracté
une maladie de peau suite l'entartrage
non je n'ai pas dit ça je pense que ce
que j'ai dit c'est que ce fameux
entarter comprend pour le verrier
entarter dernier des surréalistes est un
bon petit marchand qui vend ses photos
des gens encartés qui a tout seul son
petit réseau parce qu'il n'est jamais
seul
et que sa photo il la vend à 40 49 ans à
paris match soixante mille francs à
voici et aux télévisions etc et que
c'est un petit commerce et que je n'ai
pas envie de faire fructifier ce petit
commerce de ce monsieur gobain ou gaulin
gaudin ça peut être très très drôle mais
quand ça devient un petit commerce un
peu répétitive est bonne
la politique mais public applaudisse
tous mais si seulement ils arrivés là
avec dix ans prenait 1 d'entre nous on
rigolerait bien oui ça m'est arrivé
c'est ma mission et le lendemain il a
entarté elkabbach qui a cru que c'est
moi qui ai fait mettre la table on m'a
viré de france 2 vient de l'élire
jean-pierre franchement c'était pas mal
vous êtes toujours là ouais je suis
toujours venu pas lui bon alors on
continue alors que c'est ce qu'il a dit
le groupe y est alors voilà il a dit si
bernard henri lévy chante le nouveau le
joli chapeau 2 oh oui je chantais non
non il a dit si bernard henri lévy les
champs j'arrêterai de land'art t'es bon
moi je lui au téléphone il m'a dit si
ariel le chante j'arrête
ouais mais je ne le connais pas je n'ai
pas l'air l'argent donnez moi la lan et
wan est alors le dernier parole on va
vous donner parole comme ça ça sera fini
il m'a promis il m'a dit c'est après moi
je moi je veux pas entrer dans sa danse
à crétinerie naissance et vous en foutez
vous choque marielle
regardez toujours franck 2 voici à
nouveau en karaoké avec arielle dombasle
réel c'est samedi soir en même temps
donc si vous chantez avez vous vu le
nouveau chapeau de zozo c'est un chapeau
un chapeau rigolo il ne l'emportera plus
jamais pourquoi si vous n'entrez dont
j'ai conservé son mari s'est pas tu
merci eric 1 mais le mec il emmerde bon
non mais c'est écouter voilà on va
chanter
attention ce serait dommage josé
attendez moi je suis passé voir
s'assimiler cabade non dire des paroles
de bernard henri lévy vous connaissez la
perf ou bien on vous écoute avez vous vu
nouveau chu d'amiens pour ça
avez vous du nouveau chapeau de zozo
c'est un second enregistré la chanson
que vouloir vraiment c'est vouloir ce
fonds ne veut pas passer les mêmes
paroles en boucle donc ariel on est bien
d'accord
ce soit leur l'ère bernard henri lévy
n'est pas à l'abri de ce père en tarte
et encore elle avait refusé de sauver
bernard henry et personnes autour de
cette table je vous dis le petit
commerce continue on va pas l'arrêter
d'accord donc alors on vous retrouve à
saint denis ont tous les deux nous ça
oui le nombril du monde
gratuit alors on va passer à la suite
c'est une rubrique une question à poser
à redon bah non je lui souhaite bonne
chance et qu'elle continue à nous
enchanter aux machines éric catoire et
d'ailleurs il y aurait peu moins chaud
parce que chapeau 2 aux sages comprend
que oui de sa voix ouais ça vous pouvez
pas dire non alors voilà un truc très
beau comme vous faites la bac baroque
non mais c'était par une chose tout nous
tue bronze et non
le pape a eu des batailles aux cuisses
et wissem ben yahia pay buy ou le
papayou papageno oui mais voilà